what is this i want to talk about this
this cool mom who's going to jail
because i hate that i hate when a rat
implicates a cool mom
everybody knows that when you were in
high school you were in this weird
in-between between being a child and
being an adult you got to learn how to
be an adult and learning how to be an
adult involves drinking using drugs and
having sex
and a lot of times you need like a safe
environment or sometimes an unsafe
environment to do all of those things
that's where the cool mom
is you know becomes a thing
kathy griffin used to talk about this
like how lindsay lohan's mom dina lohan
was like you know one of the moms that
would like you know do coke with the
kids and stuff you know but you know we
had families like that we had a woman
when i grew up who had like uh you know
a big eye one big eye and sold us all
drugs and
we we loved her because
it's in someone's gotta treat you like
an adult this is my point somebody's
gotta treat you like an adult even when
you are undeserving of being treated
like an adult this woman had the goal
the unmitigated goal to treat children
like adults
kids that
are raging hormones that need a place to
do drugs and [ __ ] each other
safely in a wealthy suburban home
this woman provided a what a 6 000
square foot house big yeah a huge house
with many different rooms and alcoves
and places to go
and she created this environment where
where
cool kids or kids that were in the group
were able to go and get really drunk
test their limits find out how much
booze was too much booze how are you
supposed to learn this before you go to
college and you look like an idiot you
have to learn it
in high school you have to learn how
much booze is too much booze what do you
what what drugs
agree with your system what drugs don't
you know and what she did was was create
a vibe
truly
and and she threatened a few people
because
cool moms bad ass [ __ ] like this
woman
have to threaten the weak
because the weak are would be rats who
ruin it
for everybody and i mean
let's get into this story a little bit
because as soon as i read it i knew that
a great injustice had been done and one
of the things that you know about me is
i feel comedy
is um a way to correct all the
injustices of the world that's the way i
feel i don't think it is funny or should
be funny i think it should be about
injustices and just to discuss trans
people from any angle pro against
confused and you know the democrats are
new doing they're now doing the bill the
joe manchin and kristen cinema they're
going forward with the bipartisan
infrastructure bill
and they're carving out money so that
dave chappelle does five more specials
all about trans people on and i thought
it was a good compromise i like that
um
quote here glad she's gone los gatos
reals after mom arrested for drunken
teen sex parties shannon o'connor was
known as the cruel the cool but creepy
mom
um
read some of this ben because
i read this i was incensed
and enraged and
i don't really
have an infrastructure to go and try to
help this woman but if i did i really
would so o'connor is now facing 39
criminal charges including 12 felony
counts of child endangerment this is
more than bin laden
this is more
than osama
bin laden would have faced by the way
all of the people
who've done all of the things
the destroying of people's property
the the burning down of uh small
businesses nobody's like facing anything
this woman is facing 39 criminal charges
12 felony counts of child endangerment
for quote allegedly plying teens with
alcohol getting them drunk to the point
of vomiting and encouraging them to have
sex
you know what that used to be called
being cool
what the [ __ ]
it used to be called being cool
she's not [ __ ] the kids
she's not watching them [ __ ] she doesn't
have a jeffrey epstein-style
surveillance system right right from
what i understand right
she's simply
creating the conditions facilitating
what may happen anyway maybe she's
lighting a fire under a few of their
asses to get it going
and
she's being charged with
i knew parents back in the day
who would buy us alcohol my grandmother
would buy us a bottle of vodka when we
were in senior year
what is going on
here
what are you supposed to do at a high
school party you're supposed to get
drunk
if you're not drinking at a high school
party you're planning a school shooting
what is wrong
it's like
the craziest thing i've ever heard this
woman is being treated now she did chase
down one of the girls and threaten her
in the car
but again you have to keep a tight
circle and this is the thing that
i you there was one kid we used to hang
out with where his parents if there was
a fight at the party like his mother
would start beating people
and she'd start like there was a kid on
the ground she was kicking them
they have to defend their homestead
because when you decide to be the
parents that allow
uh
um debauchery and uh that type of thing
to go on when you allow
parties when you allow
fun when you make room for fun when you
open the door
to a good damn time people will threaten
it outsiders come in they get too drunk
they disrespect you they threaten a rat
and you gotta control
them physically many a time have i seen
fights where like the parents just get
involved because they have to defend
their home
the arrest comes a year after a number
of los gatos high school students
started a quote me too los gatos smooth
can you imagine this
can you imagine this by the way
a high school student started a me too
los gatos movement complaining about
quote rape culture at the school
and staging a rally on campus
at the time school officials
said they could do little but contact
local police about activities off campus
which they said they did the o'connor
case when apparent complained o'connor
47 was arrested in idaho
a message left on herself on wednesday
afternoon was not returned she and her
husband tech executive robert amaral
put their 4.7 million home on sale right
to move to idaho with o'connor and her
three sons
she's got three kids a 15 year old
and a 13 year old middle schooler
and i think it was a 15 year old and his
friends that she was which is a little
young it is a little in the defense of
the people maybe overreacting 15's a
little young
17
senior year is a little bit more
appropriate but we had some fun junior
year too
but and i guess when you start junior
year you are 15.
okay so she would go on snapchat
and talk to the kids and get them all
uh to come to their house and get boozed
up and [ __ ]
this is what she did
and
people have a problem with this yes
i mean
again
doesn't don't people realize
once sophomore girl goes i'm glad she's
gone it makes me feel safer
she purchased alcohol
of the teenager's choosing how cool is
that
and encourage them to have sex in her
home in a rented beach house in santa
cruz and in a cabin in lake tahoe jesus
christ you kids don't know how good you
have it
don't you know that this is never going
to happen again nobody's ever going to
buy you the alcohol you want and say
come [ __ ] lake tao on my dime it will
never happen again yes this [ __ ] had
some freak [ __ ] going on yes probably
there was some something wrong i don't
know i'm not a doctor but just looking
at this if somebody says come [ __ ] my
beach house in santa cruz and i'll get
you [ __ ] lubed up with the booze of
your choice i'm telling you right now i
know it's offensive and horrible but
wait a few years you're gonna be dying
these same puritanical monster children
are gonna be in college with their
[ __ ] hanging out of a window trying
to get [ __ ]
and they're [ __ ] and dicks i'm not
gendering this but these same kids in a
few years are just gonna be they're
gonna be dying the [ __ ] in a beach house
in santa cruz now i do understand the
concern
here
uh that the parents i get it because
it's like is she [ __ ] the kid it is
weird because why is she so into it
which is weird i get it i understand
that but i'm talking really more to the
kids now if you're a parent you're
freaked out about this i totally
understand but to the kids right now
you're kind of being [ __ ] about this
truly
so in one case when a girl was so drunk
she passed in and out of consciousness
in a bedroom o'connor brought in a
teenage boy who sexually assaulted her
while the girl cried okay well
now this isn't good
i don't read the whole article
before i do the show
i don't really do the whole thing
i do cliff notes
you know what i mean
i don't go in and
i'm am i a prosecutor
am i a lawyer
do you think i'm a lawyer
so
now this isn't good but this is the
first i'm hearing of this
and the girl says quote why did you
leave me in there with him the girl
later asked o'connor the complaint said
like why like why did you do that
you knew like what he was gonna do with
me first of all too many likes i'm not
saying it deserves sexual assault but
way too many likes o'connor just laughed
it's unclear whether any of the boys who
are juveniles will face any penalty
some of the teenagers were so drunk they
told authorities that one nearly drowned
in a hot tub and another in a bathtub
but that's funny
now the rape is not but i don't know
here's the thing
um that's one boy suffered a concussion
when he fell off the back of o'connor's
car she'd been driving the boys around
while they were drinking allowed her son
to drive in the school parking lot where
the other boy was hanging on the back
and lost his grip i mean i mean here's
the deal
the [ __ ] like to have fun
again we are we don't i don't i'm not
this is no good about
the sexual assault thing that is not
good i didn't realize that i thought
this was more of just kind of like get
the kids drunk and we drive around the
school parking lot i mean what is the
woman's really psychotic
because she's doing it in the school
i mean it's wild they moved there
specifically
because the sun
met a girl online playing a video game
and that's why they moved to the school
to encourage him to like hook up with
her and the whole thing so it's it's
very it's very orchestrated and very
weird and planned
something's wrong
we know that
we understand that but is it is it hack
to just have the same take that everyone
else is gonna have which is like damn
this woman to hell
i'm trying
now she's accused of 120 000
embezzlement schemes yeah i'm trying to
help you shannon and you're making it
hard
they make it so hard
you may have noticed his website he's
been using the nickname quote cool mom
correct i appropriated that to describe
shannon o'connor and by the way even the
the [ __ ] people are saying cool mom
the 47 year old los gatos woman accused
of throwing alcohol fueled sex parties
for teenagers and then moved to idaho
where she was accused of doing the same
there
but we were merely using the vernacular
of the kids as the mercury news reported
when the story broke o'connor 47 was
apparently known as the cool mom
since uh the older son was in middle
school and had raised eyebrows amongst
her parents for her chumminess with the
son's friends do you think it comes out
that she was just [ __ ] the kids very
possible yeah
it would have come out already probably
though
we all feel that she's a threat to the
community we experienced it i had you
know we had
uh uh uh uh people in long island that
were fun that uh parents that would
allow us to drink and use drugs and they
would drink and use drugs with us but
they never incu uh they never really
encouraged sex
i think the worst thing that happened
once was
uh somebody i knew had sex with a girl
and the father at the house watched it
like
my friend noticed he was just sitting in
a corner watching that was but that was
the worst
that happened
but nobody knew
beforehand that that was gonna happen
quote we are very grateful that the
judge decided this today and didn't
prolong this
and we got to be careful with how to
title this on youtube because they're
going to give us all kinds of problems
yeah we gotta we we were had dinner with
uh some youtubers the other night and uh
it's all in the titles
nice people huh
did you enjoy the dinner it was great i
had fun i had a lot of fun i had a lot
of fun it was good to speak to people in
los angeles it really is i i like to do
these little dinner things and see where
people are at i want to see where
people's heads are at
i think it's funny
and here's my thing with cool mom
you know listen as i read on it's more
complex
than i had originally thought
i thought she was just getting people
boozed up and saying you guys can [ __ ]
in the house but she's leading people in
the room there's people getting
assaulted that's not good
um
she's denied bail
now they're accusing of 120 grand
embezzlement scheme what does that mean
uh so 120 000 in personal charges on
company credit cards belonging to her
former employer that's a lot of booze
for the kids uh i think i was reading
and there's tons of articles about this
i was reading she like got limos for the
kids and there's a there's a lot of
stuff charged on i'm gonna tell you this
i'm gonna tell you this
many of the kids are going to look back
and say that these were the greatest
times of their lives
not all of them but many of them are
going to look back and say these were
the days
um and
it's sad
uh
but i remember you know we we didn't
nobody in long island uh was a saint who
was uh parenting us letting us have
parties nobody was a saint
but here's what we were able to do
of course we would drink and vomit and
people would have sex and there would be
fights and whatever
you know the the parents job i would
hang out with the parents i was the one
who hung out with the parents because i
didn't want to have sex with uh the
women and i enjoyed my friends and we
would get drunk but i was always curious
about uh how much money all the parents
had i always thought it was funny right
to i wanted to know how much money the
parents had so i would always talk to
the parents you know
about all kinds of things the changing
neighborhood
um you know
a lot of the things that were going on
because i knew how to get i knew how to
get into their
uh circle of trust that's true you know
i would just sit down in long island in
long island if you want to get into
someone's circle of trust you just sit
down you have a drink you stare at them
you go things feel different
am i
wrong and they will go on for an hour
they'll be like you're not wrong
and here's why
if this wasn't all creepy enough we know
that our connor and her two sons were
found with at least 10 other teenagers
in their idaho home on the day that
o'connor was arrested two weeks ago so
the party's likely continued there with
a different group of teens
so she the cops roll in
and she's got 10 kids at the house yes
partying
and the whole reason they moved there it
says the son met someone while playing
fortnite online and they believe that
o'connor moved with her sons to idaho in
order for her son to pursue a romantic
relationship with this girl and the
mother of the girl said that o'connor
herself would lavish the girl with gifts
including roses a 200 tiffany necklace
and food deliveries
is it wrong to want the best for your
children
is it wrong to want the best for your
children